[Music]
some people are great role models like
these 10 teenagers with rare diseases
who are happier than you be inspired by
our video and hit the red button below
to subscribe to our Channel challenging
beauty standards
Isabella Clare was born with Parks Weber
syndrome this rare genetic condition
made her leg grow twice it's normal size
weighing 40 pounds but the Canadian team
didn't let that stop her posing in a
bikini to challenge modern beauty
standards and inspire body positivity
Isabella also won a title in a 2015
beauty pageant in her hometown she wants
to raise awareness about her condition
and to show confidence because people
with an admirer instead of pity
ballerina Lizzie Howell will get a lot
of social media love for her inspiring
video of her impressive ballet spins it
went viral when it was shared on Twitter
while many focused on her being a
plus-sized dancer Lizzie is using her
fame to raise awareness of being a
dancer with disabilities the Delaware
teen is a spokesperson for the dancing
for you campaign and she's spoken about
how dance helped her through her
struggles with pseudotumor cerebri which
causes excess fluid around the brain
strength in a selfie
brif amy rouse Key wanted to present a
positive image of living with Crohn's
disease since being diagnosed in 2008
amy has had several surgeries to remove
many parts of her digestive system and a
team took the brave step of sharing
selfies on Facebook of her surgical
scars and her ostomy bag she wants
fellow sufferers to know their illness
is nothing to be ashamed or embarrassed
about and people who love them and still
find them perfect no matter what a
positive part Lee Anne Joyce was born
with aortic valve stenosis but despite
having a heart condition she was still a
gymnast competitive swimmer and
nationally ranked jump Roper but then
she had to stop participating because of
her condition
so she poured her energy into helping
other kids have a better hospital
experience Leanne created positive
impact for kids
the nonprofit donates movies iPads
coding books and more citizens of
hospitals across the u.s. by the time
land graduates high school and 2018 they
will likely have Ray
over $100,000 brave Abey Abey was Ken
when she was diagnosed with Turner
syndrome which only affects females the
girl from North Carolina had many health
challenges in childhood including hip
dysplasia hearing loss dyslexia and
dysgraphia the syndrome can include
heart defects and infertility too but
Abby remains positive and excited about
the prospect of adoption and when she
was 13 she dressed the best her role
model Merida from brave and an inspiring
photoshoot
dancing on Gabe Adams were born without
arms and legs due to Hannah heart
syndrome but the Utah team doesn't let
his lack of limb stop him from enjoying
dance he got into dancing because he
wanted to prove to himself and others
there was more to him than the kid in
the wheelchair
Gabe's first performed in a seventh
grade talent show and aims to join a
competitive team to butterfly boy John
Gilligan was born with a rare incurable
skin disorder epidermolysis bullosa has
caused the New York team to lose 60 to
70 percent of his skin as his skin is so
fragile he has spent his life wrapped in
bandages known as butterfly boy John
will endure a lifetime of surgeries and
infections but The New Yorker and his
family are fighting for a better quality
of life they set up a go fund me page to
raise money for a special bath and
received almost three times their goal
model example resilient teen Anna
Victoria Lago signed to BM models agency
in 2017 and became the first person in
the world with microcephaly to be signed
up by a modeling agency she was born
with a rare genetic abnormality that
means her head is smaller than average
her brain is also underdeveloped doctors
told her family she would never walk or
talk but on a Victoria has exceeded
expectations although she has speech and
learning difficulties she is living life
to the full sick chick Shirah strong and
blogged about her experience of rare
disease and created an online support
group to help others she had severe pain
as
10 year old which was diagnosed as a
psychiatric illness Shaira
actually had a connective tissue disease
called ehlers-danlos and chronic pain
from reflex sympathetic dystrophy and
dysautonomia she created her network so
that girls with illnesses and
disabilities grow up knowing how
beautiful they are
and how tough they are he received a
rare champions of hopes teen advocacy
awards from global genes comfortable in
her own skin
Alberta Howe was severely bullied as a
child and called dalmatian because she
was born with more than 500 birth marks
all over her body
the Spanish teen has a rare form of
congenital melanocytic nevus Alba had
thirty surgeries as a babies to correct
several areas but she was left with
scarring she wanted to encourage body
positivity
so Alba shared photos of herself online
and then won a modeling competition to
become the public face for an
empowerment campaign she uses the
hashtag bare your birthmark on Instagram
to encourage others to embrace their
skin which peen inspires you the most
let us know in the comments and give us
a big thumbs up
[Music]